- You can be pretty savage.
It's a quality that I
want to appre--
- I'm savage in a fun way.
- That's what you think.
- I've kind of always seen that person,
ya know, the life of the party.
Maybe you don't really know them,
but you know who they are.
And I always wanted to be that,
but I just don't know how.
I'm generally not one to make
eye contact with strangers.
I assume people don't
want me to say hi to them
unless they say hi to me first.
And ya know, maybe it's my own insecurity
or lack of confidence,
but I figure we're makin'
videos, we're tryin' things.
Let's see if it's
possible to make yourself
more likable in one week.
To figure out what I had to change,
I first asked my co-workers.
- Um, hmmmm.
- One of the things
that I like about people
is when people make eye contact with me.
- Maybe if I
- Maybe getting on their level to chat
might be helpful. Ya know?
- Well, there's just a small area.
- I think a likable person is
friendly, is cons (laughing)
- They'll ask you about your day,
and they'll invest a certain amount
of time into other people.
- I always say hi to people.
- I usually wait for
people to say hi to me.
- Why? No, take initiative.
- Because I'm afraid that
they do not want me to talk to them.
- When people ask questions about others,
it makes other people feel
good because they feel
like other people care
about them. Ya know?
- Your dress. You have
a very unique style.
- Thank you.
- I know.
Do you think stuff like that
kind of helps with likability too?
- When somebody's a little
bit more put together,
I will appreciate them a little bit more.
I'm excited. Well, good luck my love.
- Ah, thank you. See ya.
- Could any of this be
validated by science?
Would these suggestions
actually make me more likable?
I reached out to some
experts and psychologists
to get an expert opinion.
Unfortunately, none of
those people replied,
so we're off to a great start.
I enlisted our research
department to see if there was
anything scientific I could do
to enhance my likability.
A study in 1996 revealed
that bright clothing
is generally associated with
positive feelings in others.
Research has also shown that
people love to answer questions
about themselves in casual conversation.
According to research published in 2013,
humor can make other
people feel close to you,
and is linked to feelings of liking.
Several studies have revealed
that social interactions
can be received more positively
if the participants smile more.
Throughout the work week I
would follow these rules,
and on the final day,
I would throw a party.
Yes, me, hosting a party.
I'm looking for my brightest,
my most colorful clothes
to wear this week,
and my options are limited.
I'm just sad I won't be able
to wear all my beautiful
This is my first slightly colorful outfit.
I feel like it's not that colorful,
but you gotta ease into it.
I don't know what I'm gonna
do if there's not anybody
in the canteen to talk to.
Hello. Hey, Alex. What's up?
Hey, Ryan.
How was your weekend?
Hey Franny. What's up?
How's it goin'?
Did you watch Game of Thrones?
Are you hoarding all this fruit?
Is that your fruit hoard?
Good, I went to Shawn's little pool party.
What did you do? Oh yeah, you were there.
- [Woman] Yeah, I was there.
- I forgot, yeah.
Usually, when I talk to people,
it's like, oh hey, can
you be in this video?
Okay, can I ask you a question
for this video or something.
So, I feel like people are surprised
that I'm talking to them with no goal,
other than to just talk.
How was your Sunday?
Did you do anything exciting this weekend?
All right, see ya.
I'm trying to be slightly
more put together
than I normally am this week,
but I realized that I
just kind of look like
and old McDonald's.
So this outfit, it may not be the most
Oh, what are these pants?
Oh, crazy pants!
I blew it.
I really, I did not do great today.
And that's on me.
Ya know, some days you
just don't want to talk,
and that was today.
But tomorrow's another day,
and it's another opportunity
to be loved by all.
Outfit
Oh, sorry.
Outfit day 3.
So I'll just try and tell a joke
to every person I meet today.
Hey, Katie. Do you want to hear a joke?
What did Arnold Schwarzenegger
call his Italian restaurant?
Pasta La Vista, baby.
(laughing)
- Ha ha. Oh my gosh.
- Ha!
- Pasta La Vista.
- Yeah.
Good?
A lot of people thought
I was gonna scare them
or do something bad, which isn't great.
But I think just the more
that I do it, probably,
the more normal it's gonna seem, so
Maybe the unnaturalness of it.
Like, people could tell
that it was being forced.
I think that's kind of maybe the only way
that it becomes natural
is to kind of force
yourself to do it at first.
And then maybe it will be
more natural as you go.
It's very exhausting.
This is the most colorful thing I own.
I can't wait until I can
dress like shit again.
I decided to dye my hair before the party
to signify my transformation
into a social butterfly.
Getting party supplies.
Bubble liquid, I got
streamers, I got balloons,
gonna try and make some balloon animals.
All right, decorations are sorted,
and the only thing left to do is wait.
So, hopefully people come.
People cannot resist food.
You put out food, you put
out drinks, people come.
Yeah, go ahead.
Sit, ya know, enjoy.
Get a beverage.
(festive clarinet music)
Party's winding down kind of quick.
I did see some people walking by,
and I tried to lure them in,
and they kind of ignored me.
So, that was a low point,
but I feel like it's going okay.
- She seemed, I would say,
more interested in talking about us.
- I don't think she's ever
asked about my weekend.
- Yeah, I don't know, I
- Sara is a hell of a host.
- I talked to Sara.
She was super cool.
We played with bubbles.
- There was a certain
part during the party
where I saw that the
bubbles had died down,
and I was like, I wonder if
anyone was gonna get them.
- She refilled it like that.
- Beeline!
- She seemed particularly, like
- Yeah, confident
- She was really nice.
She introduced herself
to me, which was nice.
We had met one time before, so
- I got free beer, I got free cookies,
I got free cake,
so I could definitely
say she was a great host.
- I don't interact with her very much,
but on the times that I have,
she's been very nice.
- Same here.
- Same.
- I saw her introducing herself
to people she didn't know.
Something I haven't seen her do before.
- She offered us a seat,
she even gave up her seat for us.
- Hearing what people
thought about the party
made me realize that, ya know,
putting in the effort can yield results.
I really didn't realize
before how I came off,
just because it did
not occur to me, truly,
to ever do these things.
Even though they seem like common sense.
I definitely feel, like more
comfortable talking to people,
and I'm excited to get to know more people
and connect with them.